patricia lasst uns doch direkt mit dir
beginnen du hast heute das emotionale
interview mit wladimir klitschko geführt
welcher satz ist denn bei dir am meisten
hängen geblieben das sind so viele sätze
denn es war ein interview das mich ganz
tief berührt hat es ist ein mensch der
mitten aus dem krieg zu uns kam ein satz
der mir im ort bled ist wir haben keine
zeit mehr
wenn wir hier sprechen wird weiter
angegriffen prasseln weiter die bomben
auf mein land sagte er und genau das hat
uns dann auch paul ronzheimer sind im
gespräch bestätigt zugeschaltet aus kiew
der sagte ich muss jemand kurz sagen ich
weiß nie was gehört hat aber hier hinter
mir ein großer anschlag gerade zu hören
also dieser mann der sich aufgemacht dem
das grauen dieses krieges auch im
gesicht geschrieben stand es war hier so
leise im studio wie ich das noch nie in
meinem leben erlebt hat man hat jedem
wort gelauscht all den schilderungen
gelauscht er uns mitgebracht hat und
dieser brutale krieg dessen bilder wir
hier ja gerade journalisten jeden tag
sehen es damit so viel näher gerückt und
hat so viel mehr noch das herz berührt
das leid der menschen dort wurde so
eindringlich noch einmal sichtbar und
eben auch fühlbar durch dieses interview
bela du hast bestimmt auch reingeschaut
in das interview mit vladimir klitschko
wie sind deine empfindungen also dass
dieses interview dass das hat glaube ich
jeden der es gesehen hat unglaublich
berührt
der sagt es gab viele sätze das war ja
wissen ja man das sagen darf aber es war
ja war ja eine unglaubliche
wortgewalt die da von ihm ausging und
ich habe mich in kurzen moment gefragt
wie wie also da ist deutsch eine hat
fremdsprache für ihn aber trotzdem ist
war ja unglaublich poetisch auch in all
den darstellungen auch aber auch
unglaublich klar und präzise und das hat
mich sehr sehr
beeindruckt aber was mich besonders
berührt hat war der satz unsere kinder
haben keine zukunft also
und wir sehen ja hier das ja nicht mal
zwei kilometer weit entfernt von hier
der hauptbahnhof wo immer noch tausende
jeden tag ankommen bevor sie dann nach
deutschland weiter verteilt werden
entsprechend dann auch und manchmal gehe
ich der abends tatsächlich vorbei denn
die stehen in den bussen dann sind dann
die die die jungen meistens mitte mit
ihren jungen kindern gleich natürlich
froh hier zu sein das sieht man aber
auch natürlich voller schrecken vor dem
was sie da erlebt haben also da kann man
nur sagen wirklich gut ab auch vor
dieser reise um nochmal das bewusstsein
zu schaffen was jetzt passieren muss und
das schadete im interview schilderte
dass wladimir klitschko auch nochmal
ganz eindringlich denn er sagte
natürlich ist er dankbar dass wir diesen
kindern den müttern den menschen die
dort ankommen helfen aber natürlich
wollen die kinder nur eins nach hause
und deren natürlich bis heute nicht
verstanden die kann das auch überhaupt
gar nicht verstehen dass es dieses
zuhause nicht mehr gibt das ist dieses
jahr diesen alltag den sie hatten mit
freunden draußen sein in die schule
gehen draußen zu spielen dass es mit
einem mal vorbei ist das können diese
kinder die schreckliches erleben
schreckliche szene hat dort ganz
eindringlich auch geschildert von einem
jungen mit dem er gesprochen hat der
erst 14 jahre alt ist und der erleben
musste wie sein vater erschossen wurde
vor seinen augen der erleben musste wie
auf ihn selbst geschossen wurde der dann
am boden lag mehrfach getroffen und die
hosen ging offenbar davon aus dass ihnen
auch am kopf getroffen haben das haben
sie aber nur seine kapuze hat ein hobby
auf und deswegen sind sie weiter
gegangen weil sie dachten dieses kind
ist tot und mit diesem jungen hat er
gesprochen und er sagte dieser junge
wird nie wieder derselbe sein er wird
nie wieder das kind sein dass er einmal
war und dass man die schilderungen auch
die mich besonders berührt haben ohne
diesen jungen zu kennen ohne ein gesicht
vor augen zu haben finde ich ist das
etwas das das herz so so tief berührt
und das ist ja nur ein schicksal von
allen menschen die gerade dieses
schicksal teilen absolut und
mich hat das total berührt also als
vater einer tochter fünf jahre zwei
flugstunden von hier passiert genau das
was gerade beschrieben wurde von
wladimir klitschko und das zeigt dass es
in europa passiert das ist vor unserer
haustür das ist bei uns passiert und
wenn man sich überlegt dass wir
auch von ihm noch mal sehr deutlich
aufgefordert wurden hier nicht nur hin
zu schauen sondern auch zu handeln
dann war das ein sehr sehr
eindringlicher appell und noch mal sehr
deutlich zu machen auch dass es etwas
ist was uns alle auch hier in berlin
gerade mit blick auf diese geteilte
stadt noch einmal zu vergegenwärtigen
und deutlich zu machen nicht er ist der
held sondern die heldinnen und helden
sind die die das zuhause der kinder der
familie verteidigen die journalisten die
vor ort darüber berichten es gibt so
viele gesichter von helden das war für
mich der beeindruckte moment als das
noch mal deutlich gemacht hat was ich
auch sehr stark fand an der stelle die
wortwahl klar wie du schon gesagt dass
bilder und vor allem aber auch die art
und weise wie er das gesagt hat er hat
die dinge ganz klar formuliert er hat
aber nicht nur mit dem finger auf andere
gezeigt sondern er hat sich auch dankbar
gezeigt und das ist in einer solch
extremen situation finde ich nicht immer
selbstverständlich
also für mich hat er auch so gewirkt
aber trotz allem noch einen klaren kopf
hat und genau weiß was zu tun ist und
vor allem was er auch hat und das kommt
natürlich auch aus seiner sportler zeit
er hat ein kämpferherz genauso wie sein
bruder und das ist glaube ich in solchen
situationen ganz ganz wichtig niemals
aufzugeben dankbar zu sein für das was
man noch hart dankbar zu sein für
diejenigen die helfen rund aber klar zu
formulieren was man noch braucht und das
war ebenso dabei sei fast schon
unangenehm er sagte irgendwann wir
wollen nicht immer nur fordern und
fordern er wirkte dann fast bescheiden
mit dieser bitte seinem land zu helfen
nicht nur mit humanitärer hilfe auch mit
waffen wir haben auch er über einen
möglichen exportstopp importstopp
gesprochen dass wir uns endlich diese
abhängigkeit der russischen energie
beenden und er war in dieser forderung
dennoch war so höflich ob er wohl wenn
man an diesem gespräch teilgenommen hat
man selbst sich fast geschenkt hat wenn
man gefühlt hat wie können wir das
machen wie können wir all diese menschen
im stich lassen wie können wir auf die
wirtschaft und die folgen jetzt in
dieser sekunde schauen wo wir solche
schilderungen hier würde ich gerne
einmal herbott bachrain im herbst
passieren und zugeschaltet schön dass
sie heute mit dabei sind meine frage ist
an sie natürlich müssen wir uns schämen
jedenfalls müssen wir uns fragen ob wir
nicht einen verhängnisvollen hang zur
besserwisserei haben wir neigen ja dazu
die ukraine zu erklären was richtig ist
und was nicht richtig ist oder was man
an ihrer stelle besser tun sollte wir
waren im geleitzug der europäer er die
bremse und dass wir in der lokomotive
gesessen haben dann schreiben müssen wir
uns nicht aber wir müssen uns schon
selbst fragen ob wir das getan haben was
wir hätten tun müssen und ob wir jetzt
im moment das tun was notwendig ist bei
dem frage bei der frage des importstopps
für gas und bin ich etwas vorsichtiger
wenn wir jetzt sagt dass es stimmt in
der sache stimmt es ja durch den bezug
dieser rohstoffe finanzieren wir
jedenfalls mittelbar den krieg profis
das stimmt aber ich möchte dann gerne
wissen wo bekommen wir dann diese
rohstoffe her von wem in welcher menge
zu welchen preisen und wenn wissen nicht
bekommen was für auswirkungen hat das
ich habe in den letzten tagen mehrfach
gelesen auch von repräsentanten meiner
partei anders leute die ein
überdurchschnittlich hohes einkommen
haben gut fünfstellig
hohe pensionen bekommen oder bekommen
werden dass sie aufrufen ein bisschen
den gürtel enger zu schnallen wir
müssten bescheidener werden und und und
wir müssen uns mal in die situation von
leuten versetzen da ist schon der gürtel
auf dem letzten loch die gönnt es nicht
noch enger schnallen und ich möchte dass
erhält dass diejenigen die politische
verantwortung tragen genauso was sie
meinen und mit ihren forderungen nicht
im dubiosen bleiben
absolut also ich finde diese forderungen
teile ich absolut wir müssen für
irgendeinen plan habe ich habe derzeit
aber irgendwie den eindruck sollte putin
uns jetzt ganz schnell den gashahn
zudrehen dann haben wir den notfallplan
erstmals erarbeitet worden wir haben ja
die erste stufe bereits ausgerufen dann
haben wir was vorliegen nun aber von
selber die initiative das
vorbei bei notfallplänen und so weiter
dann würde ich natürlich erst mal der
industrie der strom abgestellt werden
und jetzt aufgrund der energiepreise
passiert ist schon das
produktionsstätten nicht mehr alle
maschinen am laufen haben also schon
jetzt ist es nicht so als würde in der
industrie schon gar kein energieproblem
da sein wer hat noch nicht mal hinter
uns aber das hat ja überall spuren
hinterlassen ich glaube nur wir müssen
uns diesem problem jetzt stellen und ich
glaube wir müssen jetzt an diesen
lösungen arbeiten es kommt mir so vor
als würden wir das ein bisschen vor uns
herschieben und das macht mir sorge
schon ist zu passiv also
bei aller kritik auch für tempo glaube
ich schon dass wir nicht das nicht vor
uns herschieben sondern dass wir eine
sehr entschlossene bundesregierung
erleben die entschlossen handelt die
auch über die parteigrenzen hinweg über
die eigene programmatik springt und ganz
klar die themen die jetzt von
dringlichkeit sind eher stimmig anderen
ausgaben für die bundesländer auch bei
der frage der der energiepreise auch bei
der frage der benzinpreise bei all den
fragen die die lebenswirklichkeit
betreffen schnell antworten und lösungen
zu geben und dennoch hat der boss bach
recht wenn er sagt es gibt viel zu viele
funktionäre die an dieser stelle
pauschal immer mehr und absoluter
fordern aber diejenigen die wirklich den
gürtel schon auf der letzten loch
schnalle tragen um die ist es geht es
doch letztlich auch zu kümmern und das
muss passieren das muss politisch
passieren und deshalb ärgern auch die
haltungsnoten gerade von cdu und csu
politikern die jahrelang in
verantwortung waren gerade wenn es um
die verteidigungspolitik ging und die
frage wie wir unsere bundeswehr
aufstellen dann frage ich mich schon wer
hat da verantwortung getragen und
deshalb ist es besser mein appell nicht
zurück zu schauen sondern gemeinsam nach
vorne zu schauen